(gentle music)
- I dump your ass.
(dramatic music)
♪ You're as cold as ice ♪
(laughing)
(slapping)
- Back to the caravan park, then.
- [Boy] Hey maybe you don't have to leave.
I heard they're lookin' for a new cleaner.
(tense music)
- What the hell are you doing?
- I'm dumping you.
For her.
- (laughs) Are you mental?
She's a slag.
- Yeah, you're right, but so am I.
(gentle uplifting music)
- I'm not a slag.
- Me neither, it just sounded good.
Just keep walking.
♪ Turn around ♪
♪ Look at what you see ♪
♪ In their face ♪
- It's only Maeve Wiley,
has anyone noticed whether it had teeth?
(laughing)
- I can't lose you again.
(dramatic music)
- You won't lose me.
- Do you promise?
- Promise.
(dramatic music)
- El, c'mon let's go.
- Just roll up your sleeve, you fool.
(laughing)
This one.
I'm a virgin.
- What?
- I, I'm a virgin.
(banging)
(upbeat cheery music)
- Henderson.
(laughing)
Henderson, he's back, he's back!
- I'm back, you got the job!
- I got the job!
(tooting)
(cheering)
(gagging)
(laughing)
- You ready?
(slow dramatic music)
(laughing)
(whistling)
(cheering)
♪ And the storm clouds gathered around ♪
- I'm comin' for you, Otis.
(laughing)
(dramatic music)
(upbeat music)
♪ 'Cause we are living
in a material world ♪
♪ And I am a material girl ♪
♪ You know that we are
living in a material world ♪
♪ And I am a material girl ♪
- Thanks for the gain.
- No worries.
- And the chat.
- Oh, and
- Don't worry, you were never here.
- To (mumbles)
- See you later, pet.
(dramatic music)
- Ah, maybe you guys should,
you know, stand back.
- No.
- Just step back.
- Step back!
- No!
- Seriously.
If you die, I die.
- Okay.
(horn blowing)
(clapping)
- Man, that's the thing about perverts.
It's hard-wired into 'em, you know,
they just can't help themselves.
(ripping)
(laughing)
So, you just have to take away his toy.
- No, please, not the camera.
- No, no, wait, wait, wait,
Tommy, Tommy. (laughs)
- It's okay.
Here you go, man.
(cracking)
(laughing)
C'mon, let's go, the
game's about to start.
(dramatic music)
- Give me that curly whirly,
or I will break your face.
- Okay.
(crackling)
- Ah, yeah, see you
tomorrow, shit biscuit.
- So, remember, once you get in there
- Pretend like I don't care.
- You don't care.
- I don't care.
- There you go, you're
learnin', my friend.
You're learnin'.
Hey.
- What?
- C'mon, you look great, okay?
You look great, okay.
Now, you're gonna go in there,
look like a million bucks.
- Yeah!
- And, you're gonna slam down
- Like a lion (growls)
- Yeah, don't do that, okay?
- Okay.
- Good luck.
(dramatic music)
(upbeat music)
♪ It's gotta be a strange twist of fate ♪
♪ Telling me that heaven can wait ♪
♪ Telling me to get it right this time ♪
♪ Life doesn't mean a thing ♪
♪ Without the love you bring ♪
(upbeat music)
(dramatic music)
- Wow, she looks
- Pretty.
(upbeat music)
♪ New sensation ♪
- Hi, Mom.
♪ In perfect moments ♪
- Oh, you look fabulous
♪ Well so impossible to refuse ♪
- [Boy] Thanks.